uh well it is hard to believe just two
and a half years after the biggest
contraction in the uk economy for 300
years we're talking about what could be
a bigger economic crisis than covid
energy prices soaring with war in
ukraine inflation at levels not seen for
40 years concerns about poverty and
vulnerable people struggling to heat or
eat it's pretty grim and it will of
course be the political background for
years to come so what should the next
prime minister do well philip hammond
became chancellor in the economic
uncertainty after the brexit referendum
he joins us now thank you very much for
being with us pleasure um i'm very
interested to hear your take on what the
economic picture actually is and what
the next months and potentially years
could look like how bad could it be
well it looks to me that it's very
challenging in the short term
but i think that the longer term
prognosis is a bit better
for the uk
if i were advising the incoming prime
minister
my advice would be to be very honest
with the british people about the
challenges we're facing in the short
term and how we're going to deal with
them
of course the government is going to
have to provide support
to deal with massive energy bills in the
short term
but i think the incoming prime
minister's got to be clear about what
the government can do and what it can't
do it can help with the short-term
pressures the bit of this uh in energy
inflation which is temporary cyclical
related to the war in ukraine but what
we're talking about here is people not
being able to afford to heat their homes
and and
and the government will can and should
intervene to help with that short-term
pressure
but to the extent that some element of
the increase in energy costs is going to
be structural long-term
as we
seek to become more energy-independent
in the future as we seek to decarbonize
in the future
government's got to be honest with
people that represents a change in our
priorities for consumption
and i think this has always been a a bit
of an issue that we've had about being
open and honest with people about what
the decarbonization agenda over the
medium and long term what does that mean
in layman terms
it means do you mean the green agenda
the green agenda it means that energy
is going to be more expensive than it
was before the current crisis not the
levels it is now because those levels
are driven uh to a very significant
extent by short-term temporary factors
um but we are going to have to face the
fact
that to
decarbonize our economy to
tackle global warming um we are going to
have in the long term higher energy
prices than we were used to having a
year a couple of years ago and i think
the government just needs to be honest
and open um with people we also need to
be clear that the short-term measures
that that i'm sure will be announced in
the next few days uh to help people over
this winter have got to be paid for
somehow they can't all just be done
through borrowing we're dealing with an
inflation crisis
borrowing adds more stimulus to the
economy that is exactly the opposite of
what we should be trying to do to dampen
down inflation
by finding a way to pay for it do you
mean spending cuts it means
re-prioritizing and that's what people
around the world are doing they're
saying look we've got this program over
that does re-prioritising mean spending
cuts it means postponing or delaying
things that the government might have
wanted to do in the winter of 22 23.
we need to push that money into helping
people with energy bills just as people
would do with their own budgets if a
problem comes up
you you immediately re-prioritize that's
what you do the government has to do the
same it can't just go out and borrow
hundreds of billions of pounds more
because that will only
that will only uh stimulate more
inflation you're concerned that the
truth is what liz trusts effectively
will be doing well i'm i'm i would be
concerned if that was what the new
government decides to do i don't think
it will i think it will certainly want
to do some borrowing um but i hope that
it will do some reprioritization as well
reflecting the fact that inflation is
the challenge
reflecting the fact that inflation is
the challenge we've also been talking an
awful lot about tax cuts um which you
soon but also clearly liz truss at
seeing tax cuts as a priority something
that the ifs has said that could add
to the
inflation would tax cuts out of
inflation yes i mean tax cuts now um
everything else being equal would uh
deliver an inflationary stimulus that is
not the right thing to do i think david
davis tax cuts aren't the right thing to
do right now i think david davis said
earlier and i'd agree with him that um
we are a party that advocates low taxes
we need the new government to have a
very clear set of conservative
philosophical principles including the
desire to contain the state keep taxes
as low as possible but those have to be
the long-term guiding principles for our
policy agenda in the short term we have
to be pragmatic and cutting taxes uh at
a time when we have a huge deficit 160
billion pounds probably
this year of government borrowing when
inflation is the major problem we have
to tackle is simply not the answer and
and of course the other thing is
throughout this decade the 2020s we
always knew we were going to have
exceptional pressure on public services
because of the aging profile of our
population if the government can manage
to hold taxes stable that will be an
immense achievement in my view um liz
trust has acknowledged this morning that
tax cuts would benefit the wealthier
more than those on lower incomes or of
course those and benefits as well
does that add to your view that right
now is not the time for tax cuts well it
depends how you structure them but i
think there are many reasons why tax
cuts in the immediate future will not be
the right way to tackle this crisis i
think
the government needs to provide targeted
support to those most in need around the
immediate crisis over energy bills and
we don't know what the future is going
to be but there is a good chance that
energy inflation will abate
during the course of 2023 and we will
find that we've got over this immediate
crisis um you were also talking about
borrowing and
the concerns that you have about
borrowing are you worried that the
conservative reputation for fiscal
responsibility you had the austerity
years of course with george osborne uh
you were someone who i think was
described as eeyore by some of the
tabloids in your time are you concerned
that the conservative reputation for
fiscal responsibility is at stake right
now
yes and i'm concerned that the
conservative reputation for competent
government is at stake and i think the
new government
needs to
decide from day one to be honest with
the public
to reach out across the tory party and
beyond to show that it will be a
government that governs for the whole
country
that it's a government that's
underpinned by a clear set of principles
uh and values and those would include
sound money balanced budgets uh paying
our way in the world good tory
principles but that it is also pragmatic
and it will deal with the specific
problems that we're facing like the cost
of living crisis right now so a strong
set of underpinning values that inform
our long-term agenda but an absolute
commitment to pragmatism and competent
government competent management on a
day-to-day basis who did you vote for
uh i haven't endorsed either candidate
publicly and i'm i'm not going to do so
now okay um is there a
okay
reading between the lines it feels like
you may be more on the rishi soon
excited than the liz trust night am i
overstepping look i'm i i look at the
bookies odds i look at the polling and
i'm pretty sure we're going to have a
trust government i've worked very
closely with liz trust she was
chief secretary to the treasury while i
was chancellor she was a formidable
chief secretary she works very hard
she's very diligent
and i think she can make a very good
prime minister but
she must do it by being inclusive she'll
send a clear signal as early as tuesday
when she starts to form her cabinet and
it must be a cabinet that reflects the
talent across the conservative party and
sends a message to the country
that this will be a government that
focuses on delivery on competence on
honesty and on applying those values in
a pragmatic way nicola sturgeon on this
program said she was no shrinking violet
would you agree with that description
oh she's a tough cookie um and anyone
who's anyone who's had to deal with liz
trust as chief secretary to the treasury
negotiating their spending settlement
will
know that very well i know her as a
colleague as somebody who got things
done
and that's
a rarer commodity than you might think
in government but you asked her to do
something it would always be done
and uh that that's a pretty good
credential for being prime minister uh
we are out of time but just uh quickly
there's some speculation that boris
johnson could mount a comeback eddie
lister lord lister told me earlier on
the show that if the ball came loose
from the back of the scrum he wouldn't
rule out boris johnson picking it up
what do you make of that
i think this is fantasy i think
boris
has not been a good prime minister i
think he's damaged the office of prime
minister i think he's damaged
the tory party um and i think boris will
no doubt have a very successful career
in other fields in the future and i
think he should move on
and
put aside any idea of hanging like a
sort of malevolent shadow over the next
government he needs to let let the new
prime minister get on with his or her
job and make it clear that he's moved on
as well i do think he hasn't done that
yet then i think he hasn't done it yet
okay thank you very much indeed philip
halland